welcome to the accessible computer
science education workshop
i'm roy zimmerman with microsoft
research and i'll be the moderator for
the workshop which means i get to tell
all our speakers when they're over time
and try to get them to finish while
they're still talking
i want to thank all of you for joining
us this morning and for the next days
on this journey of exploring what more
we can do together
to make computer science education more
people with disabilities
each day we'll have 90 minutes of talks
followed by some intensive collaborative
breakout groups our speakers represent a
wide range of relevant fields each with
a deep set of related expertise
sorry folks i need to slow myself down
for our asl
translators
the breakout groups
are each charged with producing a
strategic white paper
that will be published on the events
webpage
citing all contributing authors
these white papers will be the tangible
outcomes of this workshop
i hope we'll lay the foundation for some
future
collaborative research i hope you all
plan to lean into that effort
excuse me but before we get to that i
want to introduce you to richard ladner
richard is professor emeritus in the
paul g allen school of computer science
and engineering at the university of
washington
and is one of our program committee
members richard will share a little bit
more about what to expect over the
course of the next few days together
richard